welcome back to drew's news i'm here on
the high line with my co-pilot for the
day dakota johnson
now dakota you are such an incredible
creator
and we are going to talk about your
appreciation of books
music movies everything can you talk
about this wonderful tea time yes um
my company tea time
we make movies we and tv we're a
production company and i am obsessed
with movies and shows and music and i
really love to help people discover
things
so i wanted to make lists and we started
out with a top 10 list of movies and
shows
and now we've moved into we make a
playlist we have
a book list we have
an art list like exhibits well during
the pandemic you could do these like
virtual exhibits which i thought were so
cool so we have a list of those but
it's mostly just things that
touch my heart that i think people might
like i love it it's endless bountiful
great
put you in the right direction
now we share a lot of things that we
love on this show too
um i actually call it the little yellow
book so um we're gonna smash
our two endeavors together and do our
first little yellow book tea time top
ten collaboration
and we're joining forces for one big
super list and today we're covering what
to watch and some of these are recent
releases but for some we're gonna go
back to the vault okay dakota up first
you go this first pick takes us back to
new york city in the late 1980s and it's
the documentary paris is burning
directed by jenny livingston and it is
amazing it's one of your favorites too i
couldn't believe that you put it on the
list i love it so much so much it's so
it's like really full of
life and love and acceptance and
like it explores sexuality and class and
race and it's amazing and it's gorgeous
and i want more people to see that movie
what's so special so interesting is it
is such an origin story you're like oh i
thought all these pop culture things
came from x yeah it came from this ball
culture in the late 70s and early 80s in
new york city it's like that's where
these
you know very important trends
basically were born yeah
yeah it started out with these like
amazing costumes of
like reminiscing on on like vegas show
girls and then it moved into like liza
minnelli style and paul liza minnelli
madonna like you can just see where they
grabbed from the inspiration and helped
bring it into the mainstream yeah i'm so
glad that you're bringing it back into
the forefront because this is an
absolute must watch
well i will add to that list um and i
will second the curation suggestion with
succession
everyone in this show is like you can't
take your eyes off of them it's just
about you know this epic
um family
who basically dominates you know
media
yeah their moguls think rupert murdoch
the biggest families in the world
they're horrible people
but you love them it's so fun to watch
their horribleness yeah um but so season
three is coming back brush up on season
one and two oh it's so good all right
your pick next one of the greatest shows
of last year is called i may destroy you
and
it is
completely gut
wrenching and brilliant and incredible
and honest
and
important i i think it's one of the best
shows that's ever been on television in
since the inception and history
of television
yeah of entertainment i think even
across film it's just spectacular it's
so important she's so brilliant it hurts
yeah she's that good all right another
genius changing tv as we know it we
recently were lucky enough um she
actually came to the news and did the
show z-way
fun i love her has anybody seen z-way
show
um it's fantastic
if you haven't caught it catch it um
it's a new take on late night tv
she does a very unique interesting
journalistic approach she's not a gotcha
but she gets it out of people um
brilliant woman very cool um okay my
last pick is this film called portrait
of a lady on fire um
and
it's about
two people who
in a very complicated way fall in love
and
it's actually quite pure it's not so
complicated
at the time it was very complicated now
i don't know portrait of a lady on fire
oh my god i'm so excited for you i'm so
excited and what is it about the most
beautiful movie it's um in the 18th
century and it's these two uh a woman
living in a house and a woman who's a
painter is brought in to paint her
portrait
and it's about their relationship
and
it is
it's just stunning it's like
extremely beautiful all right well thank
you because i needed a new suggestion
i'm so excited for you well to um round
it out the last suggestion i have is
season two of a show called we're here
and season one was just phenomenal the
reason i loved it was because it sort of
has this priscilla queen of the desert
kind of needs a queer eye but it goes
throughout towns in america and it is
not pushy um may we stop pushing
our principles on each other and just
find a way to embrace our differences
and find out what common ground there is
within that
um and i think the show has a very deft
hand at approaching that
and season two premieres on october 11th
which also happens to be
national coming out day
cool um so i appreciate the timeliness
of that so do i
well i'm honored to be a part of the tea
time top 10 club me too we're i mean
this is the greatest
we get to do this every month i'm so
excited
and you can get these and the rest of
our top 10 picks on both of our websites
dakota johnson
thank you doesn't cut it i just want to
say
until next time because i'm so glad
there will be one and
as always if you don't mind all right
make sure to follow time on instagram
for more dakota and we'll be right back
[Music]
you